well under secretary of state thank you
very much for talking to sky news can i
first of all ask you about
some perspective because you've as a
diplomat followed and worked on ukraine
for for many years under several
presidencies just put this moment in
context for us how serious is it how
worried should are you and how worried
should we be
well mark it's extremely worrying you
know a nation does not deploy a hundred
thousand troops on the border of another
nation and put its saboteurs inside the
country
without some malign and aggressive
intent
that is a very expensive and difficult
and dangerous operation so why now and
why now particularly
when russia itself
has only half its population vaccinated
when russians care about taking care of
covid and taking care of their schools
and their hospitals and their
infrastructure it makes no sense
let's talk you talk about uh
operations within ukraine we've heard
today that this idea of a false flag
operation russia looking for a pretext
to war they want an excuse to invade so
you say
well this is straight out of the russian
playbook to try to
through sabotage operations through
false flag operations through
blaming the other guy
to create that pretext to give an excuse
to go in
or to make it look like the ukrainians
were the aggressors when in fact the
first aggression was perhaps even done
by russians against russians to blame
the ukrainians so it's all very
dangerous and the way they operate is
very non-transparent we've had a week of
diplomacy
it appears to have gone nowhere
mark i wouldn't i wouldn't say that i
would say that
in the first instance the russians came
to the table in the u.s russia format in
the nato-russia council format and at
the organization for security and
cooperation in europe where the
ukrainians also sit and they had a
chance to
hear from all of us and particularly at
nato they heard a unified message from
30 allies including the uk
saying let's resolve any issues through
diplomacy not through war nobody needs
that now
but the the russians at the osce in
vienna said and i'm quoting it they said
if we don't hear constructive response
to our proposals within a reasonable
time frame
we'll take necessary measures to ensure
strategic balance and eliminate
unacceptable threats to our national
security they want to counter what they
see as a western aggression
on
in the eastern front of europe
again mark we put the us did nato did
osce partners did
put concrete ideas on the table to
address
a significant number of the russians
concerns we are offering greater
military transparency and restraint as
long as it's reciprocal our exercises
can get smaller if theirs do we have
long wanted to talk about intermediate
nuclear range missiles in europe and and
short range the russians are now coming
and saying let's talk so let's have
another round and really get down to
brass tacks if these are the issues
they're concerned about we should solve
them through diplomacy not through
military blackmail
is america prepared to go to war with
russia
if it invades ukraine
what we are talking about here is
helping the ukrainians to defend
themselves
and preparing massive consequences
economic and political for moscow if it
walks away from the diplomatic table and
chooses aggression instead and we all
have to do that we can't allow countries
to change international borders by force
we'll have a free-for-all out there in
the world
but president putin already did that he
did that in crimea he did and he did
president obama at the time effectively
ignored him so
we know from history that sanctions
don't tend to work so you know
if they do invade what then that
question hasn't been answered what will
you
america do if russia goes ahead and
invades beyond sanctions first of all
mark to your premise uh i was involved
in the
preparation and implementation of
consequences for russia at the beginning
of that i would remind you it looked
like moscow and its proxies were going
to go all the way to kiev and they
stopped far short of that now they did
grab crimea obviously which was a
tragedy for ukraine and international
stability
what we're preparing this time is far
more severe and painful for russia
economically in terms of its potential
complete economic isolation from the
global financial system as well as
political isolation and again why do the
russian people need that now
they need what we all need which is to
be building back better and dealing with
covid
two points on that i mean you talk about
you've talked about the russian people
quite a lot but you're assuming
understandably i guess that the russian
people will
will see your point of view not
president putin's but but why is it why
do you assume that because there is an
argument that actually they will blame
the russian people will blame you
for crippling sanctions they won't blame
their own leader they'll blame the west
again this is a completely created
conflict
of the kremlin's making
ukraine poses no threat to russia nato
poses no threat to russia they ought to
be the leadership of that country ought
to be focusing on
internal issues not provoking a conflict
so if we have to impose consequences
they will be purely brought by the
leadership of russia but in in diplomacy
you need to see
things from the other side's point of
view
so okay so let's take their side their
point of view for a moment they see nato
not as a defensive organization but as
an aggressive organization they look at
libya they look at the balkans and they
see nato as being on the offensive and
they see that as well
in ukraine they see western forces
what they see as a buffer zone between
them and the west do you do can you
understand that point of view
nato is a defensive military alliance
designed to defend the interest and the
territory of its members it has not
deployed without a un security council
resolution in the past well it did go
into the balkans but it was uh partly as
a result of a unified view of its
members that that was a direct threat to
our security in europe nato has no
gripes with russia unless russia is
coming for us we've lived side by side
since the end of the cold war some 30
years in fact nato never even put its
own forces in the new member states
until after russia invaded ukraine and
donbass so russia has created and gotten
exactly the result that it says it
doesn't want because of its own
aggressive actions so it needs to think
about that before it moves this time
is there a difference between an
incursion and an invasion i've talked
i've heard a lot of american diplomats
talk using the word incursion so if if
russia was to take the donbass region
for example but not a full-scale
invasion is there a difference between
those two or do you see that any
encroaching across the border to be the
same thing
further territorial aggression against
ukraine
further efforts that would destabilize a
democratically elected government
any of these sabotage plots
brought to ukraine by russia are
aggressive or destabilizing and will
result in firm and swift action from us
but not military action not american
boots on the ground again we have said
that the response will be
severe economic and political
consequences
and finally is this the most worried
you've been about a region you've
watched for so many years
you know i think when you're old and
gray as i am we've seen
lots of violence around the world i
don't think i've seen anything
in my lifetime that is such a
created
senseless
potential use of military
aggression
when in fact
those on the other side of the table are
saying let's talk let's work this
through and the human cost would be what
human cost will be massive obviously for
ukrainians but for russians too
and then you'll also have the risk of a
great humanitarian refugee migration uh
across europe
thank you very much indeed thank you